hey 42 here the aurora borealis
otherwise known as the Northern Lights
are one of nature's most beautiful
displays of omnipotence despite what its
name suggests the Northern Lights can be
seen almost anywhere in the world even
as far south as the equator this
phenomenon has been witnessed in
Honolulu and Singapore
however sightings that far self are
extremely rare it's most commonly
witnessed within the Arctic Circle the
South Pole also has its own version of
the aurora borealis called the Aurora
Australis underthe isn't the only planet
with aurora you would witness a similar
phenomenon if you were to stand on
Jupiter or Saturn Uranus has Aurora too
but unlike the other planets with their
wave-like aurora the Aurora on Uranus
would look like glowing dots and yes I
am talking about the planet but what
exactly causes these mysterious light
shows let's find out some Inuit believe
that the spirits of their ancestors can
be seen dancing within the lights of the
aurora the Vikings believed that the
aurora was a bridge of fire to the sky
forged by the gods well spoiler alert
according to modern science the northern
and southern lights are not dancing
spirits are a bridge of fire they are
actually caused by something much more
tangible the Sun our Sun is a 4.5 7
billion year old ball of hydrogen and
other gases fusing away in space 150
million kilometers away from planet
Earth and every once in a while it kicks
up a bit of a storm a solar storm to be
precise the Sun produces energy by
smashing hydrogen atoms together in its
core under such immense temperatures and
pressures to cause the hydrogen atoms to
fuse to form helium atoms this process
is known as nuclear fusion when atoms
are under these kinds of pressures they
turn into a mushy soup of freely moving
particles which is a fourth state of
matter known as plasma
the Sun is essentially a gigantic ball
of swirling plasma using the process of
nuclear fusion the Sun is able to turn
small amounts of matter into enormous
quantities of energy
it's how the Sun has managed to keep
producing energy for billions of years
without running out of fuel if humankind
were able to consistently replicate
nuclear fusion here on earth we would be
able to make almost infinite amount of
energy using relatively little resources
in fact if you could convert the mass of
one bag of sugar into energy it will be
enough to drive a car
non-stop for 100,000 years all this
plasma swirling around within the Sun
generates huge magnetic fields these
magnetic fields are under such immense
pressures within the Sun that sometimes
the lines of force of these magnetic
fields meet when this happens the
magnetic field is forced outwards
towards the surface of the Sun once it
reaches the sun's surface it ejects
outwards into space at great speeds
taking extremely hot gases and charged
particles also known as plasma with it
this is known as a solar flare and they
can be witnessed on a Sun surface as a
very bright spot followed by a cloud of
gas when a very large solar flare occurs
containing a significantly huge amount
of energy it is referred to as a coronal
mass ejection or CME for short the gas
clouds produced by a cm II can sometimes
be larger than the Sun itself
CME's and solar flares don't stop just
outside the Sun surface charged
particles ejected from the Sun continue
to travel outward through space over
enormous distances after traveling
through space for around two days they
will reach planet earth this is known as
the solar wind it's a constant threat on
planet Earth and it can be extremely
dangerous if the magnetic field released
from a solar flare or si ma were to hit
planet Earth it could cause the
extinction of the human
so why hasn't it after all
solar flares are taking place regularly
on the sun's surface well the solar wind
does actually hit Earth often but our
trusty planet is well-prepared we have a
defense system to protect us from the
huge amount of energy that the Sun
bombard us with on a daily basis just
like the Sun the earth produces its own
magnetic field at the Earth's core is a
ball of solid light the heat of this
iron and the pressure of the surrounding
earth turns the surrounding outer core
into flowing liquid iron the movement of
this outer liquid core produces a
magnetic field that luckily for us
encompasses the earth the Earth's
magnetic field protects us from all
sorts of harsh destructive forces that
come from far away in space including
solar flares this protective barrier is
called the Earth's magnetosphere and it
extends thousands of kilometers into
space that sounds really really large
but it's actually rather modest
Jupiter's magnetosphere extends over
seven million kilometres into space on
each side of the planet in fact on
Jupiter's night side to the side facing
away from the Sun the magnetic field
which is emitted is so large that it
reaches Saturn anyway back to earth most
of the Sun solar winds simply bounce off
the Earth's magnetosphere when it
reaches us however the magnetosphere has
too weak spots at the North and South
Poles at these two locations the
magnetic fields which protect planet
Earth are much less prevalent than they
are nearer the equator this means that a
very small percentage of the charged
particles that come from the Sun do make
their way into the Earth's atmosphere
via the too weak spots at the poles when
this happens the electrons in the solar
wind collide with oxygen and nitrogen
atoms in the Earth's atmosphere during
this interaction energy is transferred
from the atoms in the solar wind to the
Earth's oxygen and nitrogen atoms
raising these atoms energy state and
exciting them when an atom gets excited
its electrons move into an orbit further
away from its nucleus these newly
excited atoms need to release this
newfound energy to calm themselves down
and return to their baseline energy
state the oxygen and nitrogen atoms
release this energy in the form of
particles of light or photons the lights
they give out is what we call the aurora
this process of exciting atoms to cause
them to release energy in the form of
light is the exact same way that neon
lights work the Aurora are simply mother
nature's neon lights executed on a far
grander scale the only difference is
that nature uses this phenomenon in a
far subtler way than to advertise strip
bars the aurora typically appears in
vast curtains or waves of light follow
and get a stinked line across the sky
they appear this way because they are
following lines of force in the Earth's
magnetic field
yep that's right the Aurora uses the
force the different colors of the aurora
are caused by different gases in the
atmosphere each gas emits a unique color
when it's excited for example oxygen
gives off a green light when it's
excited which is the most common color
seen within the aurora nitrogen on the
other hand gives off blue and red colors
when excited
so to summarize when charged particles
released from the solar flares on the
sun's surface hit our planet at either
the North or South Pole they interact
with atoms in the Earth's atmosphere
causing their electrons to move to a
higher energy state when the electrons
drop back down to a lower energy state
they release photons tiny little
particles of light which light up the
night sky in a spectacular display of
painted waves following the natural
magnetic field lines of planet Earth
knowing how the aurora are forms may
spoil the beauty for you but I believe
there's an even greater beauty in
understanding the science behind one of
nature's most
taking performances so if you're ever
lucky enough to experience the Aurora
for yourself just take a moment to
contemplate on how truly marvelous and
magnificent the universe really is and
then take selfies thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2
you